el control de armas vuelve al centro del
debate político en eeuu tras el tiroteo
registrado en boulder colorado donde un
atacante acabó con la vida de 10
personas
el presidente joe biden pidió acción
para una mayor regulación en la venta de
armas de alta potencia como los rifles
de asalto esto no debería ser un tema
partidista ese es un tema estadounidense
salvará vidas vidas estadounidenses y
tenemos que actuar también deberíamos
prohibir las armas de asalto en el
proceso
las reformas impulsadas por barack obama
no fueron exitosas pero hoy por hoy los
demócratas cuentan con mayoría en ambas
cámaras del congreso hace dos veranos
tras otro tiroteo horrible el líder
republicano y entonces se obviar de la
mayoría mitch mcconnell prometió que
habría un debate en el senado sobre la
violencia con armas de fuego nunca
sucedió este senado liderado por los
demócratas será diferentes nadie senado
no se va a esconder no vamos a debatir y
abordar la epidemia de la violencia
armada en este país pero los
republicanos han dejado clara su
posición al respecto
mannigham era camps como muchos
estadounidenses valoro mi derecho a
portar armas en el diálogo sobre el
control de armas rara vez consideramos
cuántos estadounidenses están unidos en
su defensa y disfrute de este derecho
audios wright de acuerdo con la policía
el autor del tiroteo en colorado un
estado vulnerable a este tipo de sucesos
es un hombre de 21 años identificado
como amar al ahli we alisa residente de
una localidad cercana a denver de
acuerdo con el diario the new york times
que cita a las autoridades el victimario
compró un rifle
asalto ar-15 el 16 de marzo este hecho
se presentó una semana después de los
tiroteos ocurridos en la ciudad de
atlanta georgia que dejaron ocho
personas muertas seis de ellas mujeres
de ascendencia asiática